talk to me about free agency so the the
season didn't end the way you wanted it
to end tell me about free agency what
was that like so free agency was tough
for me um in a couple ways um I didn't
know where I wanted to uh be and what
type of deal I wanted to do um because
of you know my production uh in the last
you know a lot of people don't base off
what you did the last couple years
overall it kind of go off your last
couple you know games or whatever the
case may be and um I wasn't in the best
position with leverage team wise um and
so um you know uh the Lakers wanted to
resign me but um on a smaller deal um
but I didn't for about six million I
would I could have got more if I would
have stayed probably um also Dallas
Mavericks um I had a chance with Dallas
um they were they were off in about
three to four to five three to six um
around that
range um but with the Lakers there was a
lot of unknown you know I didn't know
you know what Austin Reed signing again
I had to be smart about that uh about uh
playing time and what my role would be
and then um you know with Dallas um
obviously you got a lot of primary ball
handlers and Shooters on that team
already so you know I kind of scoped it
out and then Milwaukee was in the mix
and um John is such a great person um
you know we talk a lot and uh he was
like you know you have an opportunity to
start here you have um um a chance to
win a championship and uh I think for me
most
importantly uh a veteran some veterans
around my team you know most of the
teams I've been on besides LeBron and AD
and them they've been young you know
Minnesota Utah all of them been young so
I I'm the vet on the team most basically
I bet on myself I bet on that I would
take lower money right now to be able to
get a bigger bag than my first big
contract um so and you know it's working
out God forbid injuries God forbid bad
play but um I've been doing a great job
of just controlling what I can control
man I know my new role is to defend and
you know I've gotten heat for that as
well but man when you come in into a
whole new role where you're defending
the best player every night people don't
understand man that that's not what I
that's not what I used to do I'm used to
coming in and getting buckets you
know so man the the whole summer man I'm
working on footwork I'm working on
lateral movement I'm working on all that
type of stuff to you know and and my hip
muscles man they like damn D damn dude
you you working now so so uh but I love
the challenge man you know what I'm
saying like it's like little things man
you think you playing OKC you good at
you good you chilling but no I got Shay
you know what I mean like you go to
Houston tomorrow I got probably got Fred
or um you know I'm saying one of the
good guards like each night you know
vessel know every player on the team I'm
guarding the best player man and it's
it's a blessing you know I've I've had
some ups and downs with it so far but um
I got a long way to go and continue to
get better at it and you know uh I've
tried to hit my guy Tony Allen you know
he's one of my old vets and uh learn
from him um but other than that man it's
it's been a blessing y defensive schemes
you your guards you're told in this
system that you're in you got to be up
you're pressuring and you know when
you're pressuring the guards that you're
defending they're going to get the
better of you a lot of times you're so
much you're so high up like can you just
tell me about you ain't got to say what
you if you defer that way or not but he
just talk talk give people behind the
scenes on
what it's like to pressure these quick
guards that high up and what you're
trying to get from it can you explain
that so our our uh you know I don't want
to get too much game plan schemes but
our initial game plan is no threes send
everything to Brooke we obviously he's
one of the best in the league at doing
what he does so if you can get that then
it's it's it's tough but where becomes
tough is if you have Donovan Mitchell
Trey young uh Tyrese hurn guys who can
shoot off the pick and roll Damen
lillards of the league it's it's tough
to um because then you you pressure and
then the screen getss higher and then he
gets a wide open three because Brooke is
in a drop so honestly I gotta be it's
basically every every pick and roll to
me is an ISO I gotta make sure I'm
sending it the right way sending it to
the screen um making sure uh you know
there's no decoys or you know buddy
Hills of the league me of the leagues
they come out and slip out the screen so
it's a lot of different schemes that you
got to learn and um you know there's
just like offense there's things you can
help yourself with like rebounding
offensive rebounding things like that
like on defense there's things you can
help yourself with if you get into the
ball earlier you know you can you can
navigate the screen better if you're off
the ball it's it's it's it's sad so um
just learn continue to learn that and
you know I have my coaches on me man
just telling me every time like would I
need to do better and you know that's
the main thing that's helped me out
Pacers got you guys believe what they
won y y'all fac them five times
4-1 41 41 was it what is it about that
team that gave y'all problems and then
the second question
Malik take me through your vision your
experience of that whole ball gate
situation with with yanis and and the
Pacers so first of all what what is
about the Pacers give give y'all
problems and second take me behind that
whole ball
situ uh their whole team is like to me
is unorthodox like even the way hurn
shoots how he plays it's not your
average point guard he's 66 almost at
the point guard position doing what he's
doing um then you got guys like buddy
held um you know the uh um who else TJ
mcconell man he comes and kills the game
man it's honestly crazy how much of an
impact he is um I think it comes down to
for us how they got our number there's
there's certain teams that just they
just got your number I don't know uh
we're still trying to figure that out
because I know we gonna play them in the
playoffs and boy it's not gonna be
pretty it's not gonna be pretty for no
oh okay call it
that me of the Memphis Minnesota the
Lakers uh Memphis we played them f uh
four or five times a year and then we
play them in the playoffs so uh the way
the league shaping up right now I think
we gonna play them in the playoffs at
two 27 or uh 18 I honestly saw our
equipment manager take the real ball so
I was just so confused on what was going
on that's why I'm sitting in there
looking at Yannis like and looking at
tyres like what is going on right now we
got the
ball we got the ball like what is going
on but uh so did you tell did you tell
him did you tell him we had that's
what's messed up for me I should have
said something but I was just so amazed
that I I ain't never seen jannis that
mad his veins was coming out his thing
he look like the Hulk bro I was like oh
uh so I I
was and then after the fact I think he
finally realized that we took the ball
but um for Yannis it was more of
respecting um that was the first that
was the one and only time we beat them
and uh uh you know even after the Vegas
game and the games they beat us before
we dapped them up said was thank a good
game you know kept it cordial you know
respectful uh the time we won they took
they tried to take the ball and then
they left and didn't even dap us up or
nothing like that like I think for him
it was more of respecting and like what
are we doing like that was his main line
like what are we doing bro like I just
scored 60 you know what's going on we
won what do you need to gain ball for
rookie who scores I mean obviously
that's that's a known thing you get your
first points you get the ball but but
you on the road my boy you ain't getting
that ball